[Music]
there is an elementary school
in shure that offers some sort of
sanctuary
a place of refuge for people on the run
but they have arrived in a city now
gripped by a humanitarian
emergency and there is little here to
keep them alive
there is no food and there is no shelter
and there is no the basic needs so
if you can you have to address the world
to come soon
a human tide of 300 000 are now camping
in this beleaguered city after a
hazardous journey from
western tigray and many here
both young and old are struggling how
are you tell me how you're feeling
some have been forced to flee their
homes others have been banished by
militias
from the neighboring region of amhara
the u.s
government has called it ethnic
cleansing
lady tawel de brahan and her daughter
have just arrived in shuri
this must be a really difficult time
she's a civil servant from a city called
humera
and she says she's lost everything she
owns
do you know where you are going to sleep
tonight
there's not much space at sahaya
elementary
and conditions at five other camps in
the city are the same
the air filled with smoke and the
continuous sound of people
coughing it's so claustrophobic
in here there's barely any room to move
inside and
new camp residents are arriving all the
time
although i don't think you can call this
a displacement camp
it's more like a test of human endurance
how are you feeling
no food no services at this elementary
school
twenty-eight-year-old fitzsim
teklahaimanat suffers from a mental
illness
and his father a priest has decided to
keep him in
chains it's the only way they can cope
with
until recently and the local hospital
can't meet demand this is the corridor
of the main reception
they are short of beds and routine
medication
like basic pain relief this man was
stitched up without an anesthetic
during our visit they know the certi
among the fifth sometimes
the war in tigre has put everyone under
terrible pressure
says the director as the physicians we
are
we are doing our best but it's really
harsh the environment
the time is harsh and still our staffs
are also
still they have this psychological
trauma including me psychological trauma
because
one of our best pharmacy staff was
killed with his family by the earth
gunshot wounds and shrapnel injuries
have become a matter of routine
but some patients can't just be patched
up
eight-year-old al abraham was shot in
the head
by militiamen in western tigray
his mother grandmother and brother were
killed
i don't have an idea because he's too
young he's eight years old
later on him his little brother is five
years old
killed by them even they thought that
this was already dead
but later on as you can see there is two
sides of the injury you can see
one was it's the bullet injury and it
was in and
by that side it was also the bleed was
get out with us
they've been caught in the middle of a
battle for power
and the war in tigre will never leave
them
john sparks sky news in shuri